what is up there reject nation my
goodness so apparently late night with a
sethland myers
they have the opening scene here of
spiderman no way home so you know we
gotta watch it absolutely
we can't lose this opportunity let's see
how this goes all right it's only like
45 seconds but
hey you better be both toby andrea and
all the sinister sick
[Music]
that's right folks
spiderman is in fact peter parker are
you spiderman's girlfriend
[Music]
dude
so many rogers posters
get your tickets now yeah
the first thing i thought i'd do is like
dude tickets
oh my goodness i didn't want that scene
to end obviously oh so okay pick it up
instantly moments after
moments after that post-credits scene
from spider-man far from home and right
away i didn't realize that people in new
york loved mysterio that much yeah man
they really looked up to quentin beck
you murdered my favorite hero
you murdered my favorite hero weird
persona
that was pretty intense i mean yes it
was pitched as opening scene but i
imagine this is still edited down a tad
bit oh yeah this is kind of like a
highlight i mean it's it for something
edited probably from something that
breathes a lot better i think they did a
decent job of making it flow because
sometimes you could really tell when
things have been tearing down but yeah i
gotta imagine these scenes will play out
longer because they've also been heavily
featured in the trailer too you know but
i think it's a really solid opening
scene like it throws you right into the
panic it throws you right into the
frenzy of the situation and we've seen
so much in the trailers how mj's life is
at stake you get that real primal vibe
from the crowd right away when you know
she's amongst the crowd looking up at
them they're all spectators looking at
the you know jay jonah jameson giving
the news report looking up at you know
spider-man up there instantly they just
start harassing her yeah
like prying and that's a moment where i
feel like it's gotta play out a little
longer because even in that little
moment that they included here i was
getting that sort of tension of just
like oh too many people and yeah
everyone's like are you spiderman's
girlfriend did you help him kill
mysterio like everyone's jumping
immediately to these conclusions i love
how human it becomes evil dies tonight
evil
40 years spider-man is terrorizing new
york
there's an angry crowd yeah that's the
first thing i think of but i love the
way that played out like they said go
for the mass the crowds gasping at it
like they become hands-on and violent
with them i hope they let that scene
walk around in that vibe a little bit
more for the actual peter let's get
attacked a little bit yeah yeah yeah
this is what it's like being spider-man
but you know it sets that stage right
away of having to protect mj yeah and
something that seems like it's going to
kind of happen throughout the film of
her life being at stake as well just
because they see that they're together
and immediately just from the
the language of their bodies their body
language
watching them together like you guys
must be together you guys must be dating
each other i mean they even have that
real like urgency moment of when he
starts swinging away and they have a guy
dodge after like leave after them and
fall to the ground which seems like a
really great visual metaphor like i
almost can imagine as this movie
progresses and as this situation gets
more tangled it's probably going to be
harder and harder for spider-man to eek
out of these situations and like here it
was such just a nice human detail like
they're grabbing him in mj then he zips
up onto the cab and then he gets one
more zip and the guy grabs his foot they
almost don't get away but they do and
it's it's pretty easy but i feel like
that's just the first of many of these
you know experiences to chip away at
them as they go and two like i
appreciate that in this clip even though
it is just a 45 second window it does
seem especially ending off with ned and
and spider-man yelling dude at each
other you know like that freak out
moment it does kind of give it that us
against the world sort of vibe and the
scooby-doo stuff that we've seen in the
trailer like the trio of them yeah it
kind of got me in that place right off
the bat which is a nice thing for me you
know one thing i i do want to quickly
mention something i think this
particular spider-man franchise has up
on the other spider-man franchises and i
don't know if i'm going to really upset
people by saying this
i do think that in terms of peter parker
and his closest companions
this is the best that it's ever been
better than james from better
like the chemistry of andrew garfield
and emma stone is like undeniably it's
so
strong and it's really hard to reach
that on camera that level of on-camera
chemistry and i don't think the other
spider-man films have that but in terms
of like my best female friend and my
best guy friend no
like the trio of them promoting the
films together feels right yeah and it
feels nice so yeah like having that set
up right away and it's neat too to see
how tom holland talked about how much
darker this film is going to be because
as much as what it's like the fun
escapism music and the dude on the phone
yeah that scene with the crowd if it's
unsettling yeah it's uncomfortable like
that
with the right hand-held camera that
could easily feel kind of unnerving and
unsettling and i hope that that's a
place they're willing to go in a movie
that has been described as being the
heaviest most challenging for peter
parker and his friends movie yes you
know i feel like that scene yeah it's
hinted at a tangibility and here it's
not really on display so i hope that
yeah the scene gets to breathe more so
that we can really feel that sort of
like oh man even though spider-man has
superpowers like this crowd wanted to
overpower him and mj right now that
might be a pretty ugly situation i mean
in terms of like this kick-off point for
a spider-man film it is easily the most
unique kick-off point it is also the
most unique opening scene they've ever
had like it's such such a different
stage in tone and i love like just
keeping the personality alive like he
gets the phone call he's talking to his
friend dude and he looks so bad behind
him
there who doesn't know who's not used to
the heights and having to balance all
this oh that's right i got to protect
you you're just walking around like oh
my god and then she's just right there
how do i stay alive right now and that's
a nice little bit as much as it feels
like cut down and stuff it is exciting
it's a really like an exciting opening
sequence yeah this is one of the most
conscientious cut downs i've ever seen i
mean like i feel like we've been doing
like a boss breakdown
because
there's so much right back there and i
didn't really notice the rogers the
musical billboards in the trailers
before but man does it
everywhere man yeah i mean i wonder
because this is coming out the same week
as episode five of hawkeye comes out i'm
hearing there's gonna be some crazy
things for that episode five so i wonder
if it'll be the first time they have
like some direct tie-in
yeah but you have like hawk episode five
and then the next day the premiere of
spider-man no way home and does make me
wonder and then you have like the
correlation of new york city hawkeye the
rogers the musical there could legit be
some type of direct tie-in to no way
home that occurs and so making it for a
real
real entertainment media experience but
this was great this was honestly great
and there's a lot to take in from a 45
second clip yeah i mean for as much as
we've covered on this one movie this
clip got me excited for actually
watching it in a way that you know i've
been like oh god am i going to be jaded
by the time i get there but yeah i got
swept up in this all right guys what'd
you think about this spider-man no way
home opening clip leave your thoughts
down below make sure to subscribe click
that notification bell because you best
bet that once we watch this movie we're
going to be working hard on that review
to get it up to you right away so you're
going to want to have your notification
bells turned on because after it comes
out we're definitely going to be doing
like a spoiler talk and everything yeah
it's going to be going to be a busy
weekend week spoiler week and then
theories galore is gonna be non-stop man
this was a really exciting opening
sequence i mean that sincerely obviously
you know we had a lot to say about this
one thing i like the music too the music
that played there was that an original
track i imagine it sounded like an
original track because it had that like
fun escapism on the adventure vibe to it
because that's when this tone started to
shift you know
like really throwing you into
perspective really stuff i mean not that
i've heard the entire thing but i'm
rooting for this score it sounds great
so far leave your thoughts down below
guys we'll catch you guys soon